The Joe Rogan experience.
How many years would have to go by before people were doing commercial space
flight. Before you decided to just take a, take a shot, see what's up.
I think it could happen tomorrow.
If somebody like comes to you with a solid concept,
we're going to put you in space, bring you right back down.
I don't think space as big a deal right now. I think that it's a big business.
Uh, and the fact that, uh,
all the richest people in the world are in it prove it. You know,
that'd be like saying, Oh my gosh, you can't ship this package.
It's going to be $5,000 on FedEx.
Nah, the fact that the richest guys in the world they're in,
it means it's very cheap and you can get the hell out of here. And.
It means,
I think it means there's a lot of like benefit is being one of the people that
innovates in space travel.
If you could come up with a thing where you send people into space and every
time you do it,
you could charge someone a hundred grand and you get like a million people a
year to give up a hundred grand and go flying into space. That's a lot of money.
Only a hundred million dollars.
A million people. Yeah, it's right.
Yeah. I mean, I don't want to talk about your past or anything.
It's not a hundred. It's a hundred thousand.
Yeah. It's a, it's not a hundred million. That's a a hundred billion.
Well, that's where you start moving commas and not zeros.
Well that's when you do math. Yeah.
So like if you're Jeff Bezos and you can make a hundred billion
doing that, I mean, you wouldn't make a hundred billion.
What if you make 50 every year just putting people in the space.
That seems very.
It's going to become a commodity very quickly.
Yeah. Putting people in space.
But space is just a high flying airplane. Right.
But if people were willing to spend a lot of money doing it and then if you can
figure out a way to escape, Earth's gravity and land on the moon,
on Mars or land on, you know, Europa I, one of the moons.
Yeah. But what if you could figure out a way to fly around
Venus and come back home? What the is the point?
The point is the experience just like the point of going to Everest is the point
being at the highest spot. Like what, who gives a.
If you enter the highest spot, nobody gives a. But the point is the experience,
the experience of going there and knowing that it's a difficult thing to do.
And then it's a, it gives you a, an unusual vision,
an unusual perspective and experience it.
Few people rarely see ad blocking
kind of disable ad-blocker sun. It gives you an option.
Tickets tomorrows will eventually cost less than $500,000. Elon Musk says, well,
thank you, Elan. What a bargain. Only a half.
A million can fly all the way around the earth and stop 72 times from
500 grand. But if they really do.
You get to that point and they probably will look,
if you go back to the invention of the first automobile in like the 18
hundreds, and then you look at what they can do today with like a,
Jamie has a Tesla model X, they go shut the up, bro. They're great.
It goes, that goes zero to 60. So fast. It doesn't seem right.
And it's a SUV there. So.
Did you driven one ludicrous mode? Yeah.
Driven one like that. Yeah. They're preposterous insane.
So you go from that old car that was like, you know,
20 horsepower to what he's got. It's insane.
Now go a thousand years from now. You, you, there's no way you can guess.
And if you look at what we can do right now,
if commercial space flight is a real thing and they're flying people into orbit,
there is no doubt in my mind that what, whatever, the amount of time it is,
whether it's 50 years or a hundred years from now,
they're going to absolutely have space flight to Mars and bring people
home. They'll probably come up with some new propulsion system, some,
some wild, crazy that we haven't even thought of before.
It's not everything it's not going to happen with this giant go straight up.
It's going to have to be something that circumnavigates in gain billion and
technology. Nah, I don't know about any of the technology,
but it's going to have to be something that circumnavigates and gain speed.
As long as you say.
[Inaudible] I, I think you know what you're talking about.
Circle.
Imagine being like at NASA, what you guys needed to do was circums.
Navigates. Exactly. Get it around. It's not going to go straight up.
Boys never go straight up. Earth spins. You gotta go with the spin of the year.
Never.
Go straight, go forward. It doesn't go straight.
It looks like it's going straight.
But it goes straight in relationship to where you're standing,
but not in relationship to the way the earth spinning and the way the planets
are aligned. So complicated. Another ad popups.
That's just doesn't even work anymore.
I thought you were supposed to be really good at this. He's the best.
That's not the problem problems. Pop up ads.
NASA is launching a 4g mobile network on the moon. Yeah. Well,
when I have six G I'm not going to settle for 4g on the moon. You.
That's like getting like one ax in the end.
Who the getting in on the moon.
How many customers are on the moon phases? It's going to be with that.
Girl that you don't even like on the moon. I just.
Wasn't impressed and Martinez. I mean, if I was worth, you know,
hundreds of billions of dollars, I think I could do better.
You got a P too. So we can either wrap this up or I could pay and we keep going.
Well, I don't care. I'll be right back. Oh yeah. You're going to dare me.
What do you got your notes? Oh, just pick it up. My, uh.
Have you thought about what I said about space travel? Yes. And I'm not sure.
Green. What I'm telling you is
as a race we take over.
We try, we go and grab.
We take over it. We fight about it. We say, this is our land. This is your land.
Right. If we'd have been in the moon, wood would be up there.
The argument is that every single technological achievement from
1969 is easier, cheaper,
and faster to reproduce today except going to the moon.
That's the argument I say, right?
Because I was born in 69 and that was cheap.
The argument is that everything from then you could do cheaper today and easier
like televisions. Well,
they didn't work at it. That's the problem.
It's the only thing that didn't work at.
The only other things they didn't work at is like
how much innovation has there been an air flight in a like commercial air
travel? Not much propellers. It's been a hundred years. Right?
They were already flying jets. When did they start flying jets? Yeah. Oh,
I guess, yeah. What was in the concrete? They stopped sort of, I guess,
with the Concord and then let that go or that thing, or they're not telling us,
or they're not telling us how far they made it into a space.
The cardboard killed people that they can't kill. Like that was, uh,
what was that? Getting you to France and like two hours or something,
something crazy. You couldn't have gone faster. They just kept it there or no,
I dunno. I think the thing that happened to them was on the runway.
I think it lost a wheel or something on the runway and killed a bunch of rich
people or ran into a tire.
It says low passenger numbers and rising maintenance costs,
Migos kind of expensive. Wasn't it? Wasn't sure.
I mean, it's super Sonic speeds. You know, man,
how the does it not break? It wasn't that bad, but it wasn't that bad.
The price. I thought, for some reason in my head,
I thought it was like a ticket thousands and thousands of dollars ticket,
just a Ferris about 500 bucks or just over a thousand dollars with today.
One year when I stopped 90, 99, I was kind of wondering,
I was stopped in 2000. That's kind of crazy.
If you think about progression,
like in 2000 you could fly at
supersonic speeds commercially. You can't do that now.
So that kind of throws a monkey wrench into the idea that things always get
better because they don't always, when they cost too much money,
they don't always get better.
I don't think it cost too much money.
They were complaining about the sound and the Sonic boom.
Oh yeah. That too, right? Yeah. Yeah. But I think there was also a danger of,
it was like people, a bunch of the last flight.
I think a bunch of people die that were very wealthy. Is that true?
Well only 13. Oh yeah. That's a little more than 13.
That's serious. Yeah. And a lot of them were very wealthy.
And I think when you get hit with those lawsuits, like,
so that's one of those things that from 2000 to 2020 did not get better,
but actually stopped. You know, it's,
it's a lot of money to get people on the moon.
It's just one of those things where I think eventually they'll get to space
tourism and it will expand past the moon.
It'll go to Mars and it's going to happen,
but it might happen a hundred years from now. You know,
it might happen 200 years from now. We might be shocked at how long it takes.
And you're pleading my case right there. Why am I playing your case?
Cause we hadn't been there.
I did it once. Yeah. It might've did it once in a bunch of Cowboys.
I went to high school in the,
in the ER or even elementary school in the seventies. Right.
And you studied history. Have you ever seen a picture of the flag on the moon?
Of course I have no through a telescope.
Oh me. Do you know? They don't have telescopes that can actually see that.
Clearly they can really? Yes. Do you know the hell? Tell him you seen him.
They don't work that way. They don't like the, there's a, there's a,
like a long distance thing. And then there's a close distance thing.
Like you could use magnifying things like binoculars and telescopes that are
like low magnification and you can get like a good image of something's not too
far away. But then when they started getting too far away, yes.
The flag is still on the moon, but [inaudible].
The Hubble is not pointed at the flag here. It goes to the Hubble space.
Telescope telescope is only 2.4 meters in diameter,
much too small resolving the larger lunar
Rover, which has a length of 3.1 meters would still require a telescope,
75 meters.
Diameter.
So whether it was bad-ass country in the world and we put a man on the moon and
he planted a flag
and we ain't showing that off. Right. But do you mean cause we're as a country,
we're like Burt, Reynolds, what are you going to do? We're going to show off.
That's what we do. But did you read what that thing just said? I,
I get your like country wisdom where you're looking at it. And you're like,
if we had this, we would have that. But if you look at that thing,
it's saying that the huddle only has a thing.
That's 2.4 meters and you'd need something much larger. Was it 75,
75 meters,
which is like almost a football field size to be able to see what's on the
moon. Like they didn't have the Hubble before. Right.
They didn't have the ability to take these high definition,
images of things that were like wait far away. Now they do.
But to have something that gets really close to things,
you need something that's even more potent salt for people.
Not like you or me. We're arguing about that we don't study. That's fine.
I'm not even, I don't even care about it. Tell you the I'm just telling you.
You brought it up on a podcast. Millions of people.
I'm totally screwed now. Uh, whatever.
You can borrow a real God that you're in a argument with.
He's gonna bring that to court. What? this guy's crazy.
He thinks Neil Armstrong's a liar.
Mm.
So what's next there aliens. I don't care about anything.
I think they're paying attention personally. Yeah.
If you were an alien, wouldn't you be fascinated by hot rod culture?
Well, uh,
I way I met an old guy a long time ago and he put it to
me the right way. He goes. What if you're just
a experiment in a young kids school project?
What if all of this that you built is basically an ant form that you have in
your head and you're just an ant farm in somebody else's head.
And somebody else's at is kind of like the matrix.
I don't know if that defends us or defines us,
but it is kind of interesting. I mean,
you can't think that you're the only thing out there or we're the only thing out
here.
If we are an ant farm and we don't know that we're in an farm
and we're living and we understand how the ant farm works.
The real problem is if the owner of the ant farm shows up
up until then we're just living. You know,
if this really is like some complex and farm for people, we're having fun.
It's all good. Yeah, no problem.
We got some weed. We had some drinks where I'm fun. We're making money,
not making money.
Your. Everything's fine.
The real problem is if the ant farm owner shows up,
that's the problem with these UFO's that keep showing up the ones that eat the
New York times puts on the front page of their newspaper.
And is that a real newspaper? Yeah, it's a real paper.
It's they do it in New York state. It's a city called Manhattan.
I've been there. And I know about it.
I just don't know about New York times being in a paper.
Well, they're more off of a paper than they are.
Not sometimes they things up, but they're more often accurate than not.
Hmm. Yeah. They were more accurate in the past and they are now,
now they're ideologically, ideologically driven. They tend to be a bit woke,
but they're still probably the best newspaper on earth woke, woke,
you know, woke.
This rules.
You know, to work woke.
Rules.
You don't give a about those, right. I to not mean either. Um,
but do you think that aliens have visited?
I'm going to give it a 50, 50, I'm going to probably lean towards yes.
Is this anything that you about on a regular.
Basis? Only when I'm checking off.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify,
watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.